I'm a microbial oceanographer and that
means i study microbes in the sea they
are super powerful engines that
basically drive how our planet works I'm
interested in how microbes in the ocean
interact with biogeochemical cycles so
both how they're influenced by the
chemistry around them so how much carbon
are they getting how much oxygen are
they getting that sort of thing and both
also sort of the other side of that coin
so how are microbes influencing how
carbon which we know is very important
for climate is cycled on our planet one
of the really exciting things and my
coat microbial oceanography that's
happened recently is that we just
finished the analysis and sequencing of
the emiliana Huxley I genome and that's
quite a mouthful so we call it a hawk's
for short we were interested in a hawk's
because it is a very unique kind of
microbe in the sea out of a group called
the cockle Litha force which is also
another mouthful so these qaakil otha
pores or eat hawks are super important
because they use carbon in these two
different ways they're photosynthetic so
just like plants or trees they can take
carbon out of the atmosphere and involve
oxygen and they also take carbon up out
of the water to build these chalk plates
but one of the reasons we're studying
this organism and we wanted to sequence
its genome in the context of
understanding climate is that we're not
sure how well these organisms are going
to do moving forward and they're very
important for how carbon is cycled in
the ocean one of the ways that we study
emiliana Huxley I or you
talks for short in my laboratory and in
fact how we study other microbes in my
laboratory is we grow different isolates
or cultures and special incubators we
give them all the light and temperature
control that they need and really try to
mimic the ocean conditions that they
came from and then we do different
experiments in the laboratory for
example one of the ones that we're
starting right now that's really
exciting is we're putting our Hux
isolates or strains under different co2
conditions so we're basically mimicking
a 2100 year level co2 in the atmosphere
which causes a shift in ocean pH and it
causes a shift and the ph of the the
water that we're growing these microbes
in and we're going to do that for the
next four years straight and part of the
reason we're going long term with this
is we want to get as many generations of
hawks as possible and we're basically
going to look at how they mutate or
adapt to that sort of change over the
long term and once we understand those
mutations and those adaptations then we
will be able to better predict where
this microbe might be in the future
ocean and what its activities will be
and part of the way we look at those
mutations and we look at its activities
as we do special tests in the laboratory
so for example we can extract the DNA or
the RNA from these organisms and
actually sequence it and look at how it
changes or mutates under this higher co2
condition we can also look at its
activities so we can add special tracers
and see how much carbon and my
be taking out through photosynthesis and
how much carbon it might be taking in
through the calcification process that
makes those small choc plates that it
covers it cell with